the other big story that continues to
engulf the nfl the movement for equality
it's now been three weeks since the
murder of george floyd there was the
murder of ray sharp brooks on friday
night in atlanta that's another
troubling incident of excessive use of
force by
police departments and we continue to
see more and more examples of nfl
players who are willing
to make it known
that when the time comes for the
national anthem to play they are going
to join the protesters and take a knee
to continue to bring attention to this
plague of excessive police violence the
latest two prominent white players
making it known what they plan to do and
this came out over the weekend on social
media baker mayfield of the browns chris
j.j watt of the texans both making it
clear to go along with bill o'brien the
texans coach who told john mclean of
houston chronicle and this came out
friday afternoon that o'brien
the head coach of the texans
is going to take a knee this movement
continues to grow
and
as a practical matter the more white
players and coaches that are involved in
it the more significant it becomes that
is what
i think was missing sorely missing the
last time around it's not missing this
time around chris and it keeps growing
and growing
well yeah i mean it's very significant
it really is and because hey at the
baseline all right
white people more times than not are the
are the root of the problem here in this
situation so that's why it's awesome to
see
so many prominent white players come
forth and make these strong statements
and everything like that and i think
that's what's different about this time
around mike i mean it's kind of a
microcosm i think of what we're seeing
in society you know i think we had a lot
of you know what they say what woke
white people who were very aware of the
injustices and things that were going on
in the world against african americans
and black people and people of color but
we're kind of just like sitting on the
sidelines watching it all happen hoping
for the best right but i think that same
group of people this time around has
said okay
i'm woke the hell with the sideline i'm
getting in the game i'm getting involved
i'm going to make a difference this time
and i think we're seeing that not only
is this a you know what we're seeing in
the nfl but what's happening in the nfl
is kind of a microcosm to all of society
and uh it's good to see because this is
what we need to do to change some of the
wrongs and issues we have in this
society
yeah i think we talked last week about
how people just go about their daily
lives
and
they see something like this this is in
the past they see it they feel bad they
know it's wrong but they just continue
to go about their lives it doesn't
puncture their bubble it doesn't affect
them personally
so
it's like spinning two different plates
on one hand
this is awful i feel bad about it on the
other hand i'm just gonna keep living my
life and i feel like this time the
plates crashed together and people had
their bubbles disrupted people had
their
awakening and all of those terms that
used to get thrown around in a
pejorative way black lives matter used
to be controversial woke social justice
worry i mean those are all points of
pride now people are standing up saying
yeah call me woke i don't care call me a
social justice warrior i don't care look
down your nose at me because i'm trying
to do the right thing i
don't care baker mayfield made that
point on social media when he elaborated
on his initial
comment indicating that he was planning
to knee everybody so upset about my
comment doesn't understand the reasoning
behind kneeling in the first place
nate boyer and colin kaepernick came to
an agreement that kneeling was the most
respectful way to support our military
while also standing up for equality i
have the utmost respect for our military
cops and people that serve our country
it's about equality and everybody being
treated the same because we are all
human it's been ignored for the for too
long and it's my fault as well for not
becoming more educated and staying
silent if i lose fans that's okay i've
always spoken my mind and that's from
the heart that's baker mayfield good for
baker mayfield good for baker i mean
that's the attitude that the nfl needs
to have hey if you don't like the fact
that people are going to be kneeling if
you get a huff and puff go ahead and
blow our house down we got other fans
you know we'll find other people to come
watch the product and by the way we
don't really believe you when you say
you're going to huff and puff and blow
our house down you're going to huff and
puff but you aren't blowing anything
down because what else are you going to
watch in the fall on sundays you love
football and you're going to watch
football and you'll you'll deal with it
you'll work through the five stages of
grief because your your sport is being
invaded by by politics and i mean it's
the first two minutes of the game anyway
it's not like it's happening during the
game itself so good for j.j watt who
made his position clear as well good for
baker mayfield who elaborated on it in a
way that it needs to be said this is the
message that needs to be sent to people
it's not about disrespecting the flag
the military or the country it's about
using that moment using that platform to
bring attention to a serious problem now
look justin jackson the chargers last
week chris he suggested maybe we won't
even need to kneel maybe it'll be it'll
be so obvious the message would be so
clear and action will be taken to the
point where it won't be necessary but
maybe three months away it's only three
months away and there's a lot's going to
have to happen to get to the point where
where
it won't be needed but right at some
point it won't be needed right if the
progress is made if the change is made
if the issues that cause the kneeling in
the first place gets solved then you
don't need to kneel anymore so that's
why i guess that's the key message
anybody out there who doesn't like the
kneeling commit to making changes that
are necessary
and then the kneeling goes away it's
that simple right
right well i mean i mean we're making
progress as we've seen i mean we think
but then things that you know
friday
exactly we think we're going in the
right direction there but then all of a
sudden something like this happens so of
course you know that justifies the
kneeling even more by the players and
everything like that first off baker
mayfield this is why people love baker
mayfield this is why you and i like him
you know this is why sometimes we got to
deal with all right every now and then
he might say something to a media member
we go oh don't say that you're better
than that or whatever it may be
but it just shows you his leadership
once again
his ability to kind of not care about
what people think about him which i have
tremendous respect for
and you know i yeah i don't think the
kneeling issue is going to go away like
to your point mike i don't think enough
progress is going to be made here in the
next two to three months to where oh
players are going to go okay we've got
the message out there no i i don't think
we have but i really do give baker
mayfield a lot of praise for you know
making a strong stance and not caring
and i think that's what the nfl has to
do a little bit here too and that's
where we hear a little bit of the lack
of leadership from ownership and things
like that like listen nfl owners nfl hey
you know
we we don't care if it's bad people
watching and they're threatening not to
watch it who cares they're bad people
let's try to appeal to the people that
are good people in this country and
trying to make it go in the right
direction so uh i think that's what
baker mayfield setting a great example
with and you know it's just great to see
so many white players and especially
another prominent white quarterback come
out in support of the movement and i
think it'll uh ring true in a lot of
people's ears who don't want to hear it
necessarily
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports